Speaker 1: So things are things are still
happening as far as Matt Gates and the possible
sex trafficking allegations. Article from The
Associated Press about Joel Greenberg Joel
Greenberg is the friend of Matt Gaetz, who pleaded
guilty earlier this year to sex trafficking. He is
asking a judge to postpone sentencing until next
year so he can keep coordinating with federal
authorities. Now our laypersons understanding of
this from the outside is that Joel Greenberg's
cooperation goes specifically to the substance
of what Matt Gaetz did and what Matt Gaetz was
involved with. That's the belief. The idea of some
kind of conspiracy involving these individuals,
I'm using that term colloquially not in the legal
sense. So Joel Greenberg says, give me more time,
I'm going to keep giving investigators stuff.
Which we believe might eventually be used to
charge Matt Gates. Greenberg asked to move
the sentencing to next March. This will give
the former local tax collector from Orlando more
time to be interviewed by federal investigators.
According to the court filing, which said the
extension was unopposed by prosecutors, meaning
they're probably getting pretty good stuff. Quote,
indeed, Mr. Greenberg's ongoing cooperation,
which will not be completed prior to his current
sentencing date, could have an impact on his final
sentence. He wants a lower sentence by continuing
to give them dirt. Greenberg is facing up to 12
years in prison after pleading guilty at last May
to six federal crimes, including sex trafficking
of a child, identity theft, stalking wire fraud
and conspiracy to bribe a public official.
Gates was not mentioned in the plea agreement,
but Greenberg's cooperation could play a role in
an ongoing investigation into whether Gates paid a
17 year old girl for sex. So let's now go to some
clips of Matt Gates. Matt Gates appeared on ABC
three. I believe this is down in Florida, and he
is asked about whether he's concerned about what's
going on with Joel Greenberg, and he says that
he's not. He's more concerned about socialism.
Speaker 3: Are you worried that you're going
to be charged based on Joel Greenberg's actions
and your associations with them and your actions
with him? I'm not. I'm way more concerned
about the socialism engulfing our nation
than the scandal,
Speaker 1: the sex
trafficking. No, we're becoming socialist.
Speaker 3: What seems to be engulfing the media?
I'm glad that people are able to view these
anonymous, baseless allegations against me through
the lens of the extortion effort that Steve Alford
was a part of that other people were a part of.
Speaker 1: Are you worried that, by the way, if
you're if you're hearing that and saying what
on earth is that about Gates? And I, I believe
maybe even his dad is somehow tied into this.
They're claiming they're being extorted or that
Gates's dad was being extorted or something like
that. Then asked more about Joel Greenberg, and
Gates basically seems to throw him under the bus
and says he regrets ever having been
associated with Joel Greenberg here.
Speaker 3: I believe there may have been a
time where Greenberg swung by the office, but
it certainly didn't have anything to do with any
bad acts on my part. No, you guys still friends
or I'm assuming the answer is no, no. When when
I became aware of some of Greenberg's misdeeds,
I deeply regretted my friendship with him and
Speaker 1: misdeeds in which
Gates is believed to be involved.
Speaker 3: That note, I want to speak to my
constituents. Go ahead, please. I do believe that
it's fair for the people of Northwest Florida to
judge me based on the associations that I've had,
and I regret my association with Joel Greenberg
politically, socially and otherwise. But when
folks evaluate that, I hope they evaluate it
alongside the good work that I've done.
Speaker 1: Yeah, unfortunately, the other
stuff he's done is also terrible. Now in Florida,
they may not think that he's from a conservative
part of Florida, represents a conservative
part of Florida. They may not see it that way,
but we still reasonably think Matt Gaetz could
end up charged with some pretty serious crimes.
And I told you, was it last week or was it Monday?
Must have been last week. Maybe it was three years
ago. I don't know. Times, times we are these days.
No, I think it was last week that Gates has hired
a who's who roster of lawyers who specialize in
defending against sex crimes. Now he's entitled
to do that. Everybody is entitled to a defense.
He's innocent until proven guilty hasn't even
been charged yet. You tend to get lawyers expert
in the subject relevant to your interactions with
the law. And so the fact that he's hiring experts
in defending sex crimes certainly points to the
probability or possibility. I guess better said
that such crimes may be what he is ultimately
charged with. We're going to follow it. Hopefully
sooner than later, we'll know where this is going.